voilà pour l'ontario melkebeke ne sera
pas en reste les vents se sont levés et
quelque trente mille clients
d'hydro-québec sont privés de courant
l'heure actuelle les régions des
laurentides la région des laurentides
plutôt est la plus touchée avec 15000
panne suivi de lanaudière de la
montérégie et de montréal
on dénombre également des pannes en
estrie et dans la région de québec
la tempête post-tropicale scinder
rappelle des souvenirs évidemment new
yorkais qui en ont vécu une et toute une
l'an dernier avec irène marie-france
page et résidents de brooklyn a vécu les
deux tempêtes on peut écouter comment
elle a vécu cette journée
et comment elle explique que certains
résidants n'est tout simplement pas
écouté les consignes d'évacuation du
maire nombreux cas ce qui avait été
évacuée l'ont fait il ya toujours
quelques quelques personnes qui vont
pouvoir rester là même en couleurs qui
vont vouloir s'aventurer mais ce sont
des cas isolés je crois oui je crois que
si par contre il ya quelques personnes
qui ont pris simple plus à la légère car
lors de l'ouragan irene d'année dernière
en fait il y avait eu beaucoup de
les personnes avaient été évacuées mais
pour pas grand chose parce qu'elle est
dommage avait pointé le porteur de balle
de match que ça dans la ville même à new
york
donc certaines personnes ont pu prendre
un peu de tout à la légère mais c'est
vrai il faut pas prendre à la légère
franchement les bords sont fort que
l'année dernière
alors voilà évidemment ce type de
phénomène est très très très suivie sur
le web par des citoyens par les
autorités aussi qui s'en servent pour
mieux informer la population on va les
rejoindre à l'instant même
badens à bien notre collaborateur ou web
bonjour bonsoir plus tôt alors dites
nous un peu comment justement se sert du
web à l'heure actuelle il ya des dangers
il ya des écueils il faut être
il faut faire attention aux fausses
informations aussi qui circulent il ya
beaucoup de fausses informations qui
circulent dans cette masse
d'informations dans ces millions de
tweets dans ces milliers de tweets que
vous pouvez voir évidemment samedi en ce
moment c'est un des mots clics les plus
utilisés je vous donnerai un exemple
d'une information erronée qui a beaucoup
circulé par exemple cette photo là on
nous disait au début qu'elle avait été
prise à washington cela tombe d'un
soldat inconnu qui est gardé par des
soldats et les gens y compris les côtes
de la radio publique américaine npr
pensait bien elle avait été prise le
jour de ce jour aujourd'hui merci madame
malheureusement on doit se laisser
mais poursuivons notre conversation plus
tard ce serait très important
à bientôt madame amina messieurs